well one year ago today the blues came to town
they were 3 and0 the Jets shut them out four
to nothing and after that the Jets went 60
and one and the blues that was their first
of eight consecutive losses but it's a new year
for checking Nino neider now Paro the short pass
it's B on this is Neer ryer with the back hand and
sted and it's still loose Neer ryer trying to dig
it free again but now it's frozen by Bennington
in the offensive zone everything starts from the
for check and look at the back pressure after you
get above the option there's Lowry that stops the
pocket in the back pressure and Bennington will
come out to help this is game 707 in the career
of Tory Krug it's been a good career 32 points
in 63 games last year now kyou off the LNG shot
rebound and hellu got enough of it branded saw
had a lot of n to shoot at but hellu made the
save and here's that save from hellu rebound and
it goes off the inside of his right leg Appleton
backhand pass but easily read picking it up in
stride Shin he's got to man cavan to the net
Cavin can't get good wood on it and hellu stopped
it things open up a little bit now Razer sharp on
the [Music] play Thomas is back he's got two
line mates with him Thomas net drive from side
Thomas back door Shin Shan stop by huk and he
stretches is out the leg can he get a hold of
it yes he can that was some good work by Conor
[Applause] huk and getting the puck to the net
you still have to ultimately get it there but
sometimes it's not just as easy as through the
slot one time or shot or dshot the blues are
doing a really good job congesting the middle
of the ice he's checked in the corner stays
upright back toward the blue line right back
to ofers the mov stick save there by Bennington
he had to reach back as he was sliding uh to his
left made a pretty good save nice Puck Movement
by the Jets samber rist it through knocked down
defly there by KW and out it goes Verana to Hayes
he'll ease that in the Blues making a change dko
took a pretty good bump there the pass for alers
he'll redirect that and get it back Nikolai elers
two points away from 400 on his career drop pass
nikov cuts to the circle now curls and finds Nate
Schmid at the line nobody in front so he makes
a partner pass scoop behind the goal by Deo c d
SC David Guston with his first goal in nearly
four years and it's one nothing WI a pck vision
pass from Cole Peretti and again you build some
offense Off the Wall look at the cycle from high
ice and you got everybody watching Co Peretti
that's how you open up the middle of the ice
against the stingy team team like the blues this
is an excellent Rim down to low ice an even better
little backhand pass three goals in the preseason
and he had only five shots on net that tells me
that he's not pressing to get offense although
he knows that he has to provide some secondary
scoring from time to time he just told me he
goes I'm just more confident I'm more ready for
win opportunities come no better example than that
and another one from Appleton two nothing Winnipeg
[Music] it's the same thing just from the
other side of the ice and and this is the
third assist goes to the coaches because this
is a plan and this is exposing a team that is
giving something up and it's off the wall low
ice to the middle of the ice worked on one side
Peretti to Gus of sin and then why not try
it from Lowry to Appleton a cycle from the
half wall to behind the net Lowry draws all of
the attention back to Nate Schmidt a man is on
him his pass ATT head for shley but Thomas
was there and a pass ahead for Jordan Kyu
right in stop by heluk a fine right leg saved
by Conor huk on kyou in the offensive zone the
Counterattack from the blues has been dangerous
and the Jets get away with one there as KY isn't
able he knocked it down the mes theof to forti
brze pass Point feed deelo couldn't hold it and
it's Kyu again Jordan Kyu in Al loone and help
B has his number one more time s missed on the
followup as Hayes will snap it around flying
in his cap but he couldn't settle it and it's a
two-man Breakaway and it's Adam Lowry short-handed
stop rebound and Von have to clear it away and
here's that short-handed chance not pressing
but you're on the defensive side a nice little
chip from nestic Brana got it back and moved
it down Brandon saw up top for faul five left
in the penalty faul to Hayes here's a shot by S
put that one wide under two left in the second
period Kyu for Krug has been all over the ice on
this power play shift he change spots it looks
like with Kyu Shen took the pass and that's off
push davage he scores the redirect a power play
goal the first of the season for St Louis and
it's two to one to injury and he does a really
good job showing the stick and just watch the
middle of the ice as he's that bumper position
and there's nowhere to go so you just try to
look for a redirect this is perfectly placed
a good skill Play Look At That positioning up and
over the shoulder of heluk tucked it we walked to
the game together today we live in the same
building and he says well now we got to meet
at the elevator every game at the exact same
time I said that's a deal the good luck J as
hell he's been so good tonight he'll play it
to the left side nuds toe Neil Pon sweeps it
in St Louis just their second row game 0 and
one they open with a shootout loss at Dallas
they had a shootout one in Seattle lost 62 to
the avalan and beat Pittsburgh Saturday 4 two
bouncing Puck all over the place in front of
the slot Thomas in his six season career high
65 points last year Schmidt is able to grab
the puck con at the net is shely Conor shoot
scor sharp side shot by Conor 3-1 Winnipeg
Conor sticks so quickly a Faceoff loss turns
into a Faceoff win because the Jets do a good job
recovering that Puck and look right here the first
thought might have been pass as Shipley's off
the back post and this stick is available but
right there Connor sees oh there's a Defender
and let Pro for pav pavich he has the blues
low goal tonight shoots it in morisy turns gave
it away centering pass here's a chance he score
oh the puck pinballs to the wrong guy if you're
a jet and it is all of a sudden one goal game
Thomas making it three to2 he gets this Puck
and he represents up going up the wall and he
thinks okay I'll keep safe I'll put it behind my
neck well there's a St Louis blue there and just
watch the way this Puck plink goes around off
of the stick off of the skate of Mason Appleton
and right to Yours Truly there goes Bennington
extra attacker on for St Louis Shipley plays
it off the boards Mark shley trying to get it
straighten away he finds bar with the empty net
stores Morgan Baron with his second makes it 4-2
Winnipeg look at all five jets in one quadrant
of the ice they're all well positioned and then
the blues CAU the puck up so they're Off to the
Races that led to the two-on one for low not ice
and then another one there shy does a really good
unselfish Thing by pulling two guys to him
and he kicks the puck to Center Ice Morgan
Baron will seal the deal it's the second of
the Season like you mentioned Dan thatman hak
has been terrific tonight the Jets are three and
three they beat St Louis four- to2 it's all over